le juge lambert poursuit son travail
dans la sphère de la mort du petit
grégory
hier ils entendaient christine villemin
une audition très difficile au terme de
laquelle la jeune femme est sorti en
larmes
aujourd'hui christine villemin et qui
est toujours la suspecte numéro 1
participe est à ce que l'on appelle une
confrontation générale
le juge d'instruction a décidé
d'organiser une telle rencontre après
avoir découvert de nouveaux éléments sur
place marcel trillât et luc basket en
début d'après midi pourtant à l'arrivée
de christine villemin au palais de
justice d'epinal c'était la même
bousculade qu'au premier jour
autour d'un être traqués une vie
désormais soumises aux quatre volontés
des hommes de lois dessinent film allait
être confronté à ses beaux-parents
partie civile dans le dossier quelques
éléments de plus robert dérisoire pour
tenter de reconstituer l'assassinât d'un
enfant noyé dans une rivière il ya plus
d'un an
le disque du mouchard d'un car scolaire
dans les indications permettent
d'allonger de dix minutes le temps d'en
christine villemin a pu disposer si elle
est coupable pour commettre le crime de
nouvelles expertises en écriture qui la
désignent ray comme l'auteur possible de
la dernière lettre du corbeau annonçant
la mort de l'enfant
les expertises en audio mettrie mettant
en doute l'authenticité d'un appels
téléphoniques du corbeau qu'elle affirme
avoir elle même enregistré enfin des
moulages d'empreintes de chaussures de
femmes et de pneus semblables à ceux de
la r5 de la mère de grégory prélevés par
les gendarmes peu après le crime sur les
berges de la vologne
ils viennent seulement plus d'un an
après d'être joint au dossier
tout ça nourrit un dossier est ce que
maintenant ce dossier et suffisants
c'est pas à nous de le dire nous nous
pensons qu'il a considérablement avancé
c'est aux magistrats encore une fois de
prendre nos responsabilités dans cette
affaire
depuis plus de cinq heures dans le
secret du bureau du juge lambert et sin
villemin est confrontée une fois de plus
aux soupçons aux intimes convictions des
uns et des autres épreuves de force de
la dernière chance c'est peu probable
il faudra sans doute attendre encore
quelques semaines avant que les
magistrats se décide à trancher non lieu
ou réincarcération et renvoi devant les
assises